Salut aujourd'hui vous avez vu c'est une caméra
différentes et c'est une prise de vue un petit peu différente j'ai eu un Nokia 8 et le Nokia 8 à la
particularité de pouvoir filmer en avant le devant et l'arrière de l'écran voilà
Super drôle , ça me fait beaucoup rire!  Et je me suis dit qu'il y avait quand même des vidéos génial à faire avec ça je
vous en reparlerai à la fin sur les idées que je vais vous allez me dire ce que vous en pensez ou pas
En tout cas pour aujourd'hui et comme vous l'avez sûrement vu dans le titre j'ai dû mettre ça dans le titre c'est vraiment le bon matos pour
répondre à quelque chose que vous m'aviez souvent demandé l'année dernière et un petit peu cette année de comment on fait pour mélanger les cartes à
l'américaine à chaque fois que j'ai un jeu de cartes je fais ça dans les vidéos certains et certaines d'entre vous savent que j'ai fait de
la cartomagie pendant des années donc ok je vous apprends à faire un mélange américain
en main, sans table sans rien alors pour commencer bien sûr
il faut vous munir d'un jeu de cartes ça c'est un jeu de 52 cartes c'est à dire c'est un
54 sans les joker et on va différencier les grandes tranches ici des petites tranches ici ok comme cette caméra est situé à l'arrière du
téléphone vous voyez
exactement ce que je vois moi en même temps c'est un POV de cartes toi même tu sais vous commencez par mettre le majeur
et l'annulaire sur les petites tranches comme ça
l'index vient se recourber comme ça sur le dos et le pouce mais sur la petite tranche en pause et donc vous avez une tenue
qui ressemble
grossièrement à ça
l'idée et je vous propose de commencer par vous entrainer par ça c'est de pouvoir mettre l'index sur la grande tranche et l'auriculaire sur l'autre grande
tranche pourquoi je vais vous dire pourquoi pour pouvoir tenir le jeu comme ceux ci il doit être tenu fermement vous devez pouvoir le retourner
comme ça à l'envers sans que toutes les cartes tombe on revient à la position précédente vous allez placé l'autre main devant dans le
but de réceptionner la moitié du paquet pour sa
l'index va appuyer un petit peu pour courber les cartes comme ça ça fait une espèce de pont et le pouce va effeuiller
gentiment les cartes comme ça lentement alors pour bien
effeuiller il faut pas placer le pouce à la perpendiculaire de la petite tranche supérieure au contraire si vous l'emmenez presque parallèle
ça va vous permettre de laisser tomber les cartes
tranquillement donc en appuyant sur l'index et en laissant le pouce comme ça lâcher les cartes aux fur et à mesure comme dans tous les domaines faite
les choses étape par étape et
entraînez-vous à chaque étape avant de passer à la suivante vous allez donc effeuillé à peu près la moitié du paquet qui va tomber dans
la main gauche la main droite va relever comme ça ce demi paquet pour le placer dans la même position
en symétrie parfaite les cartes elles se font face en dessous chaque petite tranche vous avez le majeur et l'annulaire au dessus de chaque
petite frange vous avez le pouce et vous avez les index comme ça qu'ils peuvent appuyer dans le dos des cartes
je pense que jusqu'ici tout va bien je pense aussi que je suis
près de la caméra mais comme j'ai pas les bras assez long en fait pour pour le faire sinon
remarquer ce que j'ai fait sous les petites tranches
il ya vraiment une phalange
complète qui dépasse qui déborde alors c'est vraiment important que ça déborde parce qu'à un moment donné va falloir replié un petit peu comme ça
sous les paquets pour les tenir et c'est d'ailleurs notre prochaine étape maintenant vous allez forcer l'annulaire et le majeur
pour écraser pour retenir un petit peu comme cela vous fait bien voir les positions comme ça vous pourrez remettre la vidéo si vous avez
besoin les index vont appuyer un peu pour courber l'ensemble et les pouces vont effeuiller les cartes comme ça
cette étape là elle est très importante à maîtriser avant de passer à la suite
il faut vraiment savoir tenir ses deux paquets pour pouvoir appuyer comme ça en les tenant et en effeuillant en s'entrainant donc
retenez bien le pouce pas trop perpendiculaire au contraire un peu parallèle pour effeuiller les cartes le plus lentement possible
si après vous savez faire ça
vous savez faire le mélange à l'américaine donc on imagine à force d'entrainement vous êtes à l'aise avec ça et bien vous allez faire exactement la
même chose lentement mais en rapprochant les deux paquets en même temps sans les rapprocher ça donne ça
et en les rapprochant en même temps ça donne ça
Vous voyez que les cartes ont commencé à s'imbriquer un petit peu
je vais l'enfoncé encore un peu plus
là vous avez quasiment fini vous voyez bien que mes index sont toujours sur le dos et que les annuaires et les majeures
retiennent le reste contre la paume de la main
il vous reste plus qu'à appuyer sur le dessus là où il ya la jonction et de tout courbé en bas en retenant toujours
avec
avec les annulaire et les majeures pour faire littéralement un pont un U inversées mais vraiment là les pouces ils forcent sur le haut parce que
sinon
tout se barrer partout
je peux même lâché mes annulaires et mes majeurs maintenant parce que le pont en faite se tient il se suffit à lui-même
et c'est quand je vais relâcher la pression du bas c'est à dire d'ici et d'ici que mes paumes
vont se séparer un peu toujours en tenant avec les pouces sur le dessus les cartes regarder elle demande que ça d'ailleurs
elles vont commencer à s'imbriquer pour se ranger
et faire un deck complet je vous le fais à vitesse normale on a le jeu ici je fais la séparation moitié moitié
les mélanges ici comme ça
j'imbrique un peu je force en faisant mon U et je laisse toutes les cartes retombée je vous conseille donc des effeuillages lent
pareil pour le U hésitez pas à bien forcé quand vous faites le U comme ça c'est pas très simple au départ
s'il est bien fait vous pouvez même le le faire remonter les cartes à l'envers
une fois que la pression elle est mise elle est mise
voilà et en petit bonus je peux vous expliquer rapidement une coupe ciseaux
quand vous avez un jeu dans les mains et que vous voulez le couper en général vous prenez comme ça et puis vous inversez les
paquets bon c'est pas très joli c'est pas très très fluide la coupe ciseaux elle consiste à mettre le pouce sur la tranche inférieure
est toujours majeur annulaire sur la petite tranche supérieure et à se servir de l'index pour aller choper une
partie du paquet
la décoller et l'emmener sur le côté donc ça fait un pivot alors qu'en haut on a vraiment libérés un demi paquet et bien ce
demi paquet vous me mettez dans la fourche entre le pouce et l'index
opposé comme ça vous le récupérer donc ça met le paquet dans ce qu'on appelle la position de la donne et vous reposer le jeu
de cartes par au dessus et là vous venez de faire une coupe très élégante dire que la
coupe celle qu'on fait quand on sait pas faire cette coupe là c'est juste on prend puis on fait ça et
on égalise un peu la coupe ciseaux un peu plus élégante
on prend avec l'index on met et on peut même faire un petit mouvement comme ça si on veut alors oui j'ai mis Einstein dans le champ
parce que je trouvais ça un petit peu moche qu'on voit juste le sol en tout cas je trouve
intéressant ce double mode sachant qu'en plus la j'ai mis en full hd en fait les deux côtés pour voir déjà ce que ça faisait mais
j'aurais même pu filmer en 4k des deux côtés en même temps c'est plutôt balèze un
ça sert à rien les effets spéciaux
pourri par contre ce mode là m'a donné plusieurs idées des idées de vlog et surtout qu'on se refasse un petit peu des vidéos sur
le non verbal
ensemble sur la chaîne que je fasse une analyse de personnes en direct où vous la voyez d'un côté en temps réel et moi en temps
réel de l'autre qui permettrait vous aussi de vous entraîner et en tout cas de me voir parce que si je filme en 4k forcément
on verra mieux alors ma question elle est là qu'est ce que vous en force et est ce que ça vous dit dites moi dans
les commentaires dites-moi également si vous avez d'autres idées vous savez que je dis vraiment les commentaires et que je m'en inspire
pour
continuer à faire les créations de vidéos c'est pas genre mais des commentaires et je m'en fout en fait je m'en fous pas du tout
donc vraiment vous pouvez discuter et merci également à nokia qui a bien voulu m'envoyer le
téléphone là qui est le nom qui est le Nokia 8 je pense que c'est le seul téléphone actuellement qui permet
de faire ce genre de vidéos
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo comme d'habitude vous pouvez liker et vous abonner n'oubliez pas également que les places pour
l'olympia sont toujours en vente et que c'est le bon cadeau de noël idéal
vous êtes déjà environ 400 à avoir réservé les liens sont à la description à très bientôt c'est à dire à vendredi et ciao
alors si c'est pas encore fait tu peux aussi tu abonnés à la chaîne
simplement en cliquant sur le petit rond que tu vois voilà juste ici c'est ce petit rond là ça marche depuis la tablette le téléphone
c'est extrêmement pratique il n'y a plus de raison d'attendre
allez-y abonnez vous c'est cool